Bill's with us in Tucson Arizona hey
Bill how are you I'm doing well sir how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well a few years ago I was homeless
living in my car and one day God
basically told me you need to do
something right now or you're gonna wind
up under a bridge and if you'll end up
under a bridge you'll die so Rhonda
throwing the truck driving school and
now I'm an over-the-road truck driver
and I'm wondering what to do with this
money because this this job to go away
and a heartbeat also my mom's not in a
real good situation I'd like to set her
up I prayed for three things when I got
this job I wanted a decent living doing
something I loves that would enable me
to help people and I feel like honoring
my father and mother one way would be to
help take care of her and I just want to
know where I should start what should I
do with this good for you
well done so what do you make I figured
it up last night and King Kong I've ever
used about 4500 months for the last two
months very good congratulations well
done sir
well thank you you made a decision and
you acted on it very well done
all right you're right the jobs don't go
on forever nothing is forever and so do
you have any debt yes I've got about
thirty thousand in student loans and
I've got about 1500 left on my car okay
cool good well the first thing I would
tell you to do is to set aside a
thousand dollars as your starter
emergency fund and then I want you to
attack this debt as rapidly and
aggressively as you possibly can with
complete focus and reckless abandon
we're we're just pounding on the debt
because the best way to put yourself in
a position to survive a job layoff and
or to take care of your mom
somewhat is to get rid of the debt
because once that's gone you got nothing
left to do but pile up some money right
yes sir so I think you can clear this
in no time because you know just keep
your expenses down while you're over the
road and knock it out and you know as
fast as you can as a matter of fact a
few minutes ago I had an over-the-road
truck driver on here doing his debt-free
scream did you hear him
I heard he paid off thirty thousand
dollars and thirteen months if they're
making about what you're making mmm I
had one other questions where you just
called me I'm working for does he pay me
by the mile they pay me a percentage of
what they make and I have the
opportunity I'm not ready to do that
right now but I have the opportunity to
buy my own truck for about $50,000
mm-hmm and that would more than
quadruple my income but it would also
about double my expenses so I got to do
some more number crunching but I believe
that would be a substantial pay raise
and I was just wondering should I hold
off on that yes I would not do that deal
I would hold off I want you to say if
you're going to do that I want you to
pay cash for it number one but number
two the grass is not necessarily greener
there because what's what you have to do
is you're now running your own business
you've got set your own loads up and you
may very well take a pay cut and so this
company it would be the same thing they
would just take it they would take a
smaller cut and I would get a bigger cut
yeah but then when you get laid off you
on the tractor right no thank you no
thank you so I'm gonna if I'm gonna do
that I'm going to do it with cash and
that's down the road so let's get
debt-free let's build an emergency fund
after that of three to six months of
expenses let's set some money aside to
send mom some and then we'll start
saving for the tractor I've given him
about five hundred a month so far I want
to bump that up but I also want to buy a
piece of land personally as an
investment but partially so she can get
out of where she's at
not now let's get this mess cleaned up
first okay I want you to have no
payments and then save up and buy that
piece of land if you want to I can be
your mom thing okay but let's get let's
get no payments and an emergency fund
three to six months I'm talking to a guy
who 15 minutes ago was homeless right
it's a way of feel you know just the
other day right I mean this is recent
history in your life you were living in
your car so what I'm trying to do is get
you in a position that you're never
there again that's goal of one and and
that means no debt and an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
so you got fifteen thousand cash in the
bank you don't touch for anything and
you have no payments in the world you're
not vulnerable anymore does that make
sense yes sir then then we start talking
about land and tractors and all these
other things okay I ask one more
question yes sir
Sallie Mae hasn't been hounding me yet
so I've been pounding at my car trying
to get it paid off should I contact them
now or wait till the cars paid off and
then try to get a hold of them 500 a
month you only owe 1500 on the car pay
the car off okay and then try to get
ahold of Sallie Mae yeah like this month
okay where's your money going yeah you
should have plenty of money right yeah I
mean when your budget you're making
money you're not used to having any and
you you ought to be able to throw big
chunks like I'm thinking $3,000 a month
towards your debt something like that
yes yeah which your car is only 1,500
right yes yeah so that's like a half a
month so yeah you can go ahead and call
Sally you're getting ready to start
pounding her in the face we're about to
give that a woman her eviction notice
out of your life
because you're gonna clean her up in
about ten months then we're gonna build
up that emergency fund because I want to
get the vulnerability the risk away from
you then you can put be in a position to
be a blessing but only the it takes
strength to be gentle it takes strength
to be giving you can't give if you're
not strong and so I want to get you in a
place of strength so that you can be
blessing to your mom so that you can
grow a business and own your own deal
son trig someday if you want to do that
those kinds of things are what I'm
aiming you towards and so hold on I'm
gonna have our team mail you out a copy
of the book matter of fact I'll just
give you the audiobook because I'll be
better in the truck that's what the
other truck driver told me Jared told me
he did so I'll have them give you a copy
of the audio book so you can listen to
the Total Money Makeover as you're
driving and it'll get you going on this
and show you exactly why I'm hounding
you on this but I'm proud of you man
you're doing good stuff and I want you
to call me back and tell me how you're
doing sometime and and if you need more
help or have more questions you let me
know you got some good goals some good
solid things you've got a good heart and
and you pulled yourself up I'm proud of
you well done very well done